we have a grand nefarious strategy of
giving founders what we wish we had when
we were a founder
yeah it's like what would i have wanted
yeah like that's certainly how i think
about this
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell today we actually have some
news to announce um
for the first time since winter 2020
this new batch the summer 22 batch will
be in person um and we are all excited
dalton we're gonna get to see founders
in person again what do you think
it's a
a breath of fresh air
um i've been spending a lot of time in
this little room much as probably you
have to so yeah this is it's
it's really fun i'm excited
me too me too so let's talk about what
this means so
um the founders of this batch are going
to have an in-person retreat
in sonoma to kick the batch off
they're going to be able to go to weekly
meetups in san francisco
we're actually going to help
organize weekly meetups in other cities
around the world
we built some software that are going to
help founders meet each other and have
one-on-one coffees founders in the same
city
and then we're going to have a huge
end of batch celebration
after demo day in san francisco
with all the batch and the alumni
needless to say the program's still
going to be friendly to founders
participating remotely so the batch
talks office hours things like that will
still be online and we still have
founders from all over the world
participating but i have to say you know
founders i've talked to in every country
have been excited to
come here to meet us to meet their batch
mates
um
to get out in front of zoom and and get
off these cameras for a while so
i'm really really excited yeah we kind
of had a dry run a little bit last batch
where there were a lot of these
in-person meetups um and i went to a few
i know you did too and the energy was
great and so yeah now is now is the time
to make this move you know yeah the idea
that we get to renounce something that
was so quarter yc is actually quite fun
what other trends are you seeing for the
the summer 22 batch yeah i mean let's
see to go through
some of the stuff i've noticed so for
one um more applications
um i think that's
that's i think that's always a trend but
there's definitely more applications and
you know i think the uh the new yc deal
doesn't hurt on that one um and so yeah
more applications more applications to
read and the energy is feeling good man
how about you what what are you seeing
in your group
same thing i'm seeing um
teams be slightly more technical which
is exciting i mean when you work with
strong technical teams
we talk about taking punches strong
technical teams punch back and so
to me like that's always fun it's always
um much more enjoyable work with strong
technical teams but you know over the
last you know
let's say three four months what are you
seeing overall in our world i think that
people that want to do a startup because
they're excited about building something
and solving stuff for users those people
are still applying if anything those
folks that aren't making fear-based
decisions are more excited to apply to
yc and do this almost because it's more
rebellious or anti-anti-something
yes like
to to do a startup when it's like less
cool to do it
and this makes sense again if you if you
actually look at the yc data
some of the best companies we've ever
funded happened when either there was a
full downturn or at least a blip i think
we can call it a blip um like some of
what happened in 2018 but look at when
stripe was founded look at when airbnb
was founded look at when dropbox was
founded
right
yeah it's a weird trend because i agree
with you it's both a little bit like
i want to go against the flow there's
that set of founders but there's also
the set of founders who are just
strategic
who are just like hey look in the middle
of the hype cycle hiring is harder
getting access to customers is harder
like 17 of your competitors are gonna
all get funded like you know it's
it's weird because on the surface the
hype cycle looks good but when you
actually get into the dirt
the hype cycle like hurts just as much
as it helps and so you know i'm starting
talking about is in this batch who are
like yeah no this is actually like
you know they're not wishing for a
downturn but like this is the time when
it's strategic to get in the game
yeah
make hay why the sun shines right this
is where oh cool cat you know face the
price of facebook ads is dropping oh
cool like all these factors
are changing and so if you're like well
positioned this is when you go on
offense yes you're not like you're not
like defensively oh i'm gonna hide
there's a lot of folks that we talk to
that are like extremely ready to go on
offense yes yes they've been waiting for
this moment now we're also seeing a lot
more
interest in san francisco and like i
don't know like that's a dirty word i'm
not sure if i'm allowed to say the term
san francisco because we all know
the tech world doesn't exist here
anymore right yeah well it's funny there
was so much content marketing
trying to fomo everyone that everyone
was moving into whatever insert city
name you know whatever the city was this
is the next capital
and then there was a lot less content
marketing of all the people that moved
back and so i don't know who you're
talking to but a lot of the folks i've
talked to
quiet you know that were loudly talking
about moving away to whatever city name
yes you know they're much more quiet on
the move back
i've not seen as many i'm not seeing as
much of that
but yeah i think a lot of folks are
moving back right now
new york too it just seems like people
are going back to the big centers
because they're getting bored and lonely
and feel
kind of over it again this is what i'm
learning in office hours man is that
people are they want to be
where the action is
you know i think you're saying it the
right way i think the founders i talk to
they don't want to build a startup
ecosystem they want to be a part of a
startup ecosystem and it's been
interesting because we saw it you know
first in the end of batch survey when we
asked people about oh as we add more in
person components and it was like almost
unanimous the founders in the previous
batch were like
if you had told us something was
happening in the bayer we would have
moved you know and like that was a
response
we didn't necessarily expect
it's almost like you and i
were convinced
that that wouldn't be the case like i
don't know how to explain it like the
content marketing worked on me too a
little bit yeah yeah but it's like it's
not being borne out in the data that we
have about
you get what i'm saying like like we i
kind of bought into the content
marketing too but we'll see i don't know
like
i think the other thing that i'm seeing
and and it's interesting because i've
got a brother who's this age a recent
college grad
i think what's so hard for a lot of
people to see is that if you're a recent
college grad
you don't want to stay in the city you
went to school in
um you might be living with your parents
and like in comparison moving to the bay
area is
way better of an option than kind of
your current setup over the last couple
years
and so
i think that a lot of that content
marketing is unfortunately written by
like
people our age people with kids people
living in san francisco for like the
last two years who were generally pissy
about covid
and it was like less responding to
someone who might have spent a year and
a half remote doing college
or living in some small college town
locked down
and is like i want to get out of this
you know like that kind of person is uh
san francisco looks like a beacon i
think you want to be where
the action is is i think how my summary
is
versus feeling like you're in a
not where the action is so another thing
that happened recently is uh we sent a
letter to yc founders about the economic
downturn which was uh
happened to maybe get a little bit of
exposure to the to the general public
i'm not sure how that happened but it
was interesting because i've been really
impressed with how the yc founders have
responded you know what have you seen i
think that
if you're smart
you know how to look at things like that
as well as
just general press or advice
and
apply it to your specific situation
correctly
like if you're a two-person startup with
no burn
what's happening in the late stage
fundraising environment in ipos
like if that's what you're worried about
man you've got bigger problems okay
and so i think if you were able to say
well what is my actual situation am i
default alive
how much cash do i have what's my runway
and then make the right moves because
again for some folks the actual move is
to go on offense
right like we said a moment ago where
they're like okay i see so this is the
score got it time to go hard against my
competitors who are have higher burn
yeah you know
like this is a great time if you're the
underdog and your large competitor is in
trouble
right
and so i think that smart founders know
what applies to them and what doesn't
versus overly freaking out
about things that have nothing to do
with them um you know what do you think
like
you often talk about this and and it's
something that i think is becoming part
of the culture of yc where we want to
talk up to our founders versus down to
our founders like we want to talk to the
smartest kid in the class not the
dumbest kid in the class
and i think sometimes in the general
public
that's not well understood but i think
within the yc community it really is um
the feedback that we got from alums
was
universally
this caused me to take a sober look in
my situation
and if my situation was good
i'm staying on plan if my situation
wasn't i'm making changes
and you know just to your point it
wasn't
i'm freaking out
it was like okay i'm gonna take a second
and and do a sober analysis of my
company and i think what's unfortunate
is that they had just gone through this
two year cycle where investors were
basically screaming at them to burn and
raise
because investors were getting markups
and they were raising new funds and
right and so
i think that in many ways this letter
gave them a lot of people the
opportunity to say okay wait a second
like
is that strategy actually good for my
business
and um
it's obviously good for my investors
business
you know getting markups is obviously
part of their business model but is that
strategy good for my business
so um
that's been really fun to see it's been
fun to see the founders taking it in the
right way
um
probably one of the last big trends is
this new standard deal right you know
that was big news over the past
um four months and
it's interesting because i think that in
some ways
um
it was conceived of competitively people
were looking at the yc standard deal
being like oh like ycs to compete
there's so many
new seed funds out there
and i think what's interesting is if you
would kind of take it inside baseball
for a second that's really not the
reason we did it at all like take us
inside baseball a little bit dalton like
what was the strategy behind it yeah i
mean the strategy was
it's good for companies to get fully
funded the moment we accept them
and
you know
frankly we saw some stuff that looked a
little toppy to use the
wall street best terminology
you're speaking in code be literal here
what do we see
it looks
yeah um it looks like
we
we're not sure that things were
sustainable that everything would keep
going up forever how about that stocks
may not only go up
and so it seemed prudent
to
you know be
it seemed prudent to give the companies
more money so that in the event of a
market change
we were confident that everyone be fully
funded again for context i think people
forget this because of
all the crazy um
seed round warped perceptions
how much money did like
airbnb and dropbox and all those folks
raised back there how much money did
airbnb is a million under a million
these seed rounds are under a million
and and diluting over 20 over 25
like so we actually know that half a
million dollars
is slash was
enough money to build like
one of the most successful companies
ever
and it made a ton of sense
to to have this budget to raise this
money we could fund a lot of companies
it's all raised we have it dry powder
um so that no matter what happens
if you get into yc
you're good there's this saying that i
love um
the best time to fix the roof is when
the sun is shining
and you know i look at our opportunity
to create this new standard deal for for
yc founders and the fact that we have
budget to fund over 1400 companies with
this standard deal
and i think to myself like you know
i'm so happy we did that when we could
because now we're going to be able to
help so many teams that otherwise might
not
be able to do startups might not be able
to raise money
so and not be sure oh i don't know if i
want to apply to yc i don't know if i
want to start a company because i'm
afraid i've read techcrunch articles the
funding environment is rough you know
there's all these like fears out there
well it's like well yeah if you get into
yc you get half a million dollars and
like
the day we fund you it's funny like
people they almost sometimes people
don't believe us they're like wait this
is contingent on something right it's
like no we can use them no we give you
the money up front yeah no but like
don't other accelerators they have
something where they take it back if you
don't do it's like no like if you don't
kill anyone you don't violate our ethics
thing this is
this is the deal um i think what was
also interesting was to see how yc
founders used the new standard deal in
the last batch when they were
fundraising
um
you know historically
seed funding could dilute companies 25
30 even 35
i would say in more recent years that
number was around 15 to 20 percent
but we really saw a lot of founders able
to get the money they need raise their
seat around with 10
some even a little less dilution
which was like huge i mean we all know
those earlier rounds are where most of
the dilution the company happens so that
was awesome to see
the other thing and i know you saw this
in your group too it's just
founders going into fundraising with
confidence you know we talk about this
all the time we tell the founders be
confident but it's hard to be confident
when you only have six months or three
months of runway when you go into
fundraising it's a lot easier to be
confident when you come in with half a
million bucks what did you see in your
in your group
yeah i think
the best founders were just very
logical
and non-emotional
in in the way they handle this just it's
business right like the best way imagine
any financial transaction you want to
buy a house you want to buy a car you
name it the more that you can be
just a non-um not manipulated
into being emotional or to be fomo like
there's all these things if you could
just be like hey i want to buy a car
this is my budget this is what i want to
buy okay let's work it out all right i
bought the car that's how you want to
approach any kind of financial business
relationship right it's just to be
non-emotional and so that's having this
extra money helped people not
be quite as susceptible to
being told to be afraid basically right
yes
being told to be afraid and it's such a
weird thing to watch your founder
simultaneously be almost negged by an
investor and be told to raise more money
from that investor right where the
investor is like
your plan's never going to work you're
not raising enough money you're going to
die you're dedicated up if you take my
money then it would all work out and
it's like
i've been so happy to see why c founder
is able to kind of push back against all
of that and and really be sober right
like just be sober in your planning and
and
um things work out better it's just it's
funny because like we always are
optimizing for
you know we're former founders i think
it's like what would have helped me when
i was a founder
and it's just funny
how like doing that really seems to
annoy investors that we're like again
we're like giving away we're like on the
wrong team a lot they seem really bad
like i thought
like it's isn't that weird man like why
we're we we have a grand nefarious
strategy of giving founders what we wish
we had when we were a founder
i mean isn't that like so funny because
it's kind of one of the core guiding
principles of yc when we think of what
we're gonna do yeah it's like what would
i have wanted yeah like that's certainly
how i think about this yes
and and the opposite too like what would
i have thought of as [ __ ] like like
how do we not do the stuff that i would
have just like been like that's [ __ ]
who cares i mean it's hard to do in
practice it's just at the end of the day
more leverage for yc founders good
more options for yc founders good
that's the game
obviously so
anything more on the standard deal so
far so good again like the folks that
are in my group dispatch man they're
feeling they're feeling good they're
feeling very good yeah
and and probably the last trend and
maybe one of the most um
heartwarming trends is
how many alumni reach out to us and say
they're watching these videos
like how much has that come up for you
in the last six months since we got this
thing rolling
a lot i think when we first started
recording these my perception i wasn't
really sure who the audience was and i'm
maybe i'm still not sure but it
certainly would appear
that um a lot of yc alums um are
watching these which is awesome that we
have this
direct line um for
people
you know to hear hear from you and i
personally about what's going on with yc
i mean it
seems better than other forms of
communication right
you know it was interesting because you
know we put out a video it was
interesting as we put out a public video
about
making sure that you are prepared for
down economic times before we even sent
a letter
and and one of the reasons we were
inspired to kind of send a letter was
the number of alums who had watched that
video and reached out and said thank you
for doing this like we're
we're rethinking our plan and so
um i just think it's exciting to see
that the yc alumni are watching these
videos alongside prospective um founders
it's it's awesome to see
all right well i think that's it so um
in closing we are really looking forward
to meeting the next
batch which is going to happen
very soon mid-august i'm sorry mid-june
and then we're also ridiculously excited
to meet all the founders that we've
funded over the past years we're going
to do a massive alumni event in san
francisco in the fall
and so for all the people we haven't
seen in person yet we'll see you soon
dalton great to see you
sounds good bye
[Music]
[Music]
you